all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh scarlet witch fighting
wolverine in the mcu all right here's a
crazy thing so there was a tweet that
came out a little while ago and it was
basically this idea that wanda was gonna
face off against somebody from the x-men
universe and like the in doctor strange
too right making her way through the
multiverse then ultimately facing off
against one of those guys now initially
this tweet was taken as a you know for a
grain of salt right here we're just kind
of like i was like a random tweet from a
random person and then daniel rickman
responded right those guys who don't
know who that is daniel rickman he's
like a movie insider right when this guy
comes out and says hey guys like you
should know this is probably going to
happen it means it's going to happen
right like this guy just knows people
who knows people who knows people that's
what happens whenever you work in the
film industry in hollywood right you do
that long enough you make contacts you
get to know people they give you
information you give them information
different things like that it's a kind
of give and take right and he came out
and he was like yep that's exactly what
was supposed to happen that like wanda
was supposed to fight wolverine and
doctor strange too uh that she was gonna
make her way somehow into the fox verse
or something along those lines we don't
know exactly how it was gonna happen but
her and wolverine were gonna fight and
wolverine was gonna lose apparently it's
not going to be and we don't entirely
know why the prevailing theory right now
from like screen rant and mcu direct and
all these major sources out there is
that logan ended in such a wage where it
had this kind of beautiful finality for
the character of logan as he was played
by hugh jackman and that if hugh jackman
was going to come back to play the role
of wolverine one last time it wasn't
going to be to be a punching bag for the
scarlet witch and like i have to believe
there's merit to that in like the 17
years that hugh jackman played wolverine
by the time it came to an end it
probably wasn't even about the money
anymore right it was just more of the
legacy for the character that he created
because much like robert downey jr as
iron man chadwick boseman as black
panther chris evans is captain america
chris hemsworth as thor there comes a
point when you you look at that actor
and you only really see them as that
character and and i have to imagine
doing that for 17 years for almost 20
years i mean hugh jackman played
wolverine for as long as chris claremont
wrote the x-men in marvel comics that's
insane right and when you look at that
it's kind of like i'm this guy right i
mean not really right i doubt hugh
jackman was running around popping you
know pretending to pop claws although
it'd be amazing if he was
but there comes a point when you're like
people see me as this character and so
if i come back there has to be some
measure of significance to it and and it
can't be a punching bag thing because in
all honesty i feel like we would reject
that i feel like we would be mad if hugh
jackman came back to play wolverine we
only see him once and he gets beat up by
the scarlet witch i think people would
be kind of pissed right i think people
would be pretty annoying i know i would
right so it makes sense and i can really
support the idea that hugh jackman
doesn't want to come back just to get
beat up right which really begs the
question would there have been more for
his character i mean it's not like a
test bed thing it's not like they don't
know right like if hugh jackman comes
back and plays wolverine i wonder if
people fans of the mcu would be
interested in that no one's asking that
question right and if they are they're
an idiot we would love to see wolverine
like we would love to see hugh jackman
as wolverine in the mcu
no one's doubting the excitement about
that so one it leads me to believe if
that happened it'd be a one-off i mean
we don't know why the deal fell through
we just simply know that it did and one
of the things we mentioned in a previous
video i think it was an episode of the
rumor roundup or one of those was that
hugh jackman has been asked multiple
times are you going to come back and
play wolverine and in previous issues or
previous interviews it's been no i'm
done with the character more recently
it's been i haven't heard from feige in
them so it's one of those things where
he's even gone and said like i would
love to have come back and played
wolverine had they had they gotten the
fox properties earlier but even now it's
one of these things where it's like i
mean i would play him it just seems to
be one of these kind of deals where it's
like i just i mean i'll play wolverine i
just don't want to be a guy who gets
beat up in 15 minutes and that's the
last you see in my character right wolf
reigns beyond being a punching bag at
this point so in light of that assuming
it doesn't actually happen here's our
picks for who wanda is going to face off
against and doctor strange to multiverse
of madness and i think that these
particular responses
are going to blow your mind so first
things first let's start with the least
powerful of these guys magneto now i
know a lot of you guys are kind of like
the least powerful yes the least
powerful but the most significant right
so magneto is a lot of you guys know
even if only by just cursory glances and
surface exploration on the internet
magneto as as scarlet witch's father has
been a very tumultuous on-again
off-again kind of thing in marvel comics
in the old school vision and scarlet
witch story marvel basically explored
that idea because it had kind of been
solidified even in earlier stories the
really the the first time that you saw
scarlet witch and quicksilver on the
brotherhood of evil mutants which was
magneto's antithesis to the x-men like
an evil mutant team basically uh when
you look at like the avengers when wanda
and quicksilver joined the avengers team
that it was one of these things where it
was like magneto's their dad and so that
was largely explored in the original
issue miniseries vision and scholar
witch and then in more recent years
through a combination of axes that
storyline and a few others it was
believed that where scarlet witch and
quicksilver were the children of magneto
now they're not and and i have to
believe and it's never really been
confirmed i don't think but i think we'd
all be right in assuming the reason why
that choice was made is because marvel
was pissy that fox wouldn't just give
them the the x-men properties back and
so they were like well then screw it
right we saw marvel do that with a bunch
of different things they literally
stopped publishing the fantastic four
for something like three years because
they couldn't get the rights back to the
fantastic four so they were trying to
tank the team which was never going to
happen
that was a stupid stupid publishing
decision but the important thing here is
that that magneto and scarlet witch do
have a lengthy history there whether
he's her father or not and there are
some great moments that are based around
that concept a really good example of
this is the events of house of m when
you get to the conclusion now those guys
who are familiar with this you guys know
how awesome it is but like at the end of
it it's crazy a lot of you guys know
about the whole idea of house of end
that scarlet witch had warped reality
given everybody a universe that
basically fulfilled their subconscious
desires what you learn at the end of the
story is that quicksilver was the one
who got her to do it that the x-men and
the avengers were going to kill the
scarlet witch because her mental
instability was a massive danger to the
universe because of the level of power
she possessed and so quicksilver got her
to rewrite reality well in the house of
m universe like magneto finds out right
he's awakened right woken up to how
things are supposed to be and like
there's this great big huge fight
happening between like all the awoken
people right like doctor strange and all
those guys and like quicksilver and and
like the forces of magneto and all that
kind of stuff and then like magneto's
like what have you done in my name boy
he just shows up and he's just like just
bristling with just power he's mad as
hell like he's losing his mind and
quicksilver's like they were gonna kill
her and he's like i don't care so like
he freaks out loses his mind and kills
quicksilver right just literally smashes
him to death with a giant chunk of metal
it's crazy scarlet witch loses it right
she absolutely freaks and like she
resurrects quicksilver from the dead and
she's like that's it she's like i've had
enough she's like i'll set everything
back to normal she's like but we're
monsters we're freaks so like as soon as
she goes to set things back emma frost
right immediately realizes what's going
on she's like oh my god and then like
and then like wanda says it right no
more mutants and that's the end of like
like 98 of the beaten population lose
their powers like literally you pick up
with everything being set back to normal
all these kids in the xavier institute
are crying like wolverine remembers his
entire history basically anybody who's
not a mutant gets kicked out pretty much
all the mutants who are left are all
consolidated down in the xavier
institute and they're guarded by the one
sentinels the office of national
emergency so they're as much prisoners
as they are being protected but like
it's amazing man but like having
something like that would be cool
because the relationship between the two
is very very very very tenuous now the
big issue that you have here this is a
big contentious point the the most
extensive thing that we got with regards
to the idea of magneto potentially being
the father of scarlet witch was in days
of future past when it was kind of a
off-handed remark by quit silver like i
think i know that guy and kind of
alluded to the idea that like magneto
was was his father but you didn't see
like a maury povich you're like magneto
you are the father you didn't see that
as hilarious as it would have been you
didn't see anything like that so how it
is that you end up having scarlet witch
and magneto fight against each other and
have any measure of significance there
is going to be a difficult one because
at the end of the day it would just be
two mutants facing off against each
other and it would more or less be up to
the audience to decipher the
significance of it because of what we
know could potentially be going on in
the background but without that those
kind of stakes there without wanda or
magneto actually knowing that they're
biologically related the significance is
lost in the moment so again it would be
cool to see but there wouldn't really be
a whole lot in terms of having any real
meaningful impact as far as why it
matters in the first place it would just
be cool to see wanda fight magneto now
moving on to our next choice here which
is a little more powerful than magneto
and i know this is going to be a little
bit of a debate quicksilver now here's a
cool thing right a lot of people are
going to kind of be like quicksilver's
not more powerful than magnet you don't
know he kind of is right you can't hit
what you can't see and quicksilver is
probably the single fastest person in
the entirety of the marvel universe with
the exception of the runner one of the
elders of the universe who literally
just runs through space those of you
guys who don't know who that is he was
the guy who actually possessed the space
stone when when thanos was traveling
around during thanos quest gathering the
infinity stones it actually turned out
the runner was not nearly as fast as he
believed he was he was just
subconsciously using the space stone to
basically have himself move through
space at hyper speed right so he's not
as fast as he would like to believe he
is but he is technically faster than
quicksilver i mean i guess if you really
want to start getting into characters
that are that are super fast but not
official buried alien right is basically
the flash in marvel comics like he's
literally a pastiche on barry allen this
dude is stupid fast it's crazy how quick
he is but you see him for like three
issues and he's in a race and that's
basically it but quicksilver would be a
far more meaningful battle with the
scarlet witch than magneto would be and
the reason why is because quicksilver is
dead in the main marvel universe right
we know that like like aaron taylor
johnson he's gone he died in age of
ultron and while a lot of us were kind
of hoping that he would return there's
no guarantee that it would be and it
would be kind of cool to see quick
silver return uh with wanda having faces
you know having to face off against him
and then recognizing who he is right
somebody calls him quicksilver and then
for her it's like a personal vendetta
you're not quicksilver you can't use
that name right that was my brother's
name and for her it seems like a sign of
disrespect the whole wow quicksilver's
like i don't know who you're talking
about right i never met you i don't know
you and juana just starts attacking him
again the motivation though is kind of
flimsy but it'd be very easy to build on
that by just kind of focusing on wanda's
mental state right that given the power
of her influence or the influence of the
dark hold on her given everything she's
been through how the entirety of wanda
vision was designed to basically be her
going through the grieving process but
she didn't quite complete it because now
she's on the hunt for her kids and
different things like that it'd be very
cool to kind of mess with that kind of
mental psyche the biggest issue you have
with that is literally the whole of
wanda vision was about that
and i feel like we as the audience would
kind of look at that and say really
mental health again that's what we're
doing again i mean we get that it's a
big issue and it needs more attention
but like
give us something else man
you know i feel like that's something
that we as the audience would kind of
look at right and so uh kind of doing
the same gag twice doesn't necessarily
work at least when it's that on the nose
right marvel does do the same gag twice
when it comes to the mcu i mean that's
what the entire whole like 10 years were
based on but in all honesty i think it'd
be a pretty significant thing but as
cool as the fight would quit with
quicksilver would be honestly i think
the potential and because of the power
that wanda has they wouldn't have her
face off against ground level characters
like that unless there was a kind of
primal motivation a personal reason why
it's happening if what marvel wanted to
show us in doctor strange too was just
the raw power of the scarlet witch
galactus is the person to have her face
off against or at least one of them
that's my next choice here galactus
right one we've been screaming for
galactus for a long long time we've been
wanting to see him for a long time now
granted introducing galactus in the mcu
as a punching bag for scarlet witch
while it may on the surface seem like
it's something that we would reject the
reality is it would show us just how
powerful wanda is especially when it
comes to something like the power that
galactus has now the biggest issue you
have here is that the audience fully
understanding the kind of power that
wand is facing off against requires more
than galactus just can you know in the
middle of consuming a world you know
wanda runs up on him and then a great
big huge fight breaks out plus what's
the motivation there what's the purpose
behind wanda fighting galactus in the
first place i mean juan is on the hunt
for her kids why would she care if a
great big huge 2000 foot tall guy in a
purple suit is destroying a world in a
universe somewhere i mean that's not
really going to be relevant to her right
it's like us going on a road trip and
stopping because we saw like a lion
eating a gazelle and trying to save the
gazelle from the lion we wouldn't care
we'd be like damn that's crazy and then
we just keep on going right that would
be that's all that we would really do so
there really isn't a huge motivation
there and galactus is not really a
multiversal character so it's not as
though galactus would leave his universe
enter into the multiverse stumble upon
wanda and realize you've got insane
amount of power i'm gonna consume your
energy and then attack her and that's
how the fight breaks off it doesn't
really happen that way in mobile comics
i mean galactus can consume the energy
of people and a really good example of
that goes into really the final person
that i want to talk about here the
phoenix now there was a point in marvel
comics when you had rachel summers who
was actually a really the daughter of
jean grey and in cyclops from an
alternate reality called days of future
past who ended up coming to the main
marvel universe in the present timeline
and then became a host for the phoenix
force and there's a point where she and
galactus get into a fight and galactus
actually starts siphoning off all the
energy of the phoenix and feeding
himself and amping his power up so
galactus can consume the power of
individual beings if they're powerful
enough for him to care about right
somebody like thanos that's not really
going to draw any attention from
galactus on that score they have fought
and it was cool when thanos overpowered
galactus that was kind of nuts granite
galactus was exceedingly weak but still
it's it's it's a nice little notch to
have under your belt like i'd be
galactus you know like what wasn't he
kind of weak man don't worry about that
i beat him that's the important thing
it's a nice little notch to have under
your belt but the phoenix is a very very
very powerful being out there now
granted fox has never done anything good
with the phoenix they've if anything
just ruined the phoenix as a concept in
movie form the phoenix force is
incredible it's amazing right because
even the phoenix in and of itself is
very very intriguing those of you guys
who don't know what this means the
phoenix represents the sum total of all
life that that has ever currently does
and will ever exist in the entire
omniverse which includes a collection of
multiverses even though you only ever
really see the phoenix as it's confined
to marvel comics and then at the same
time the phoenix because it's so
astronomically powerful there's only one
phoenix force across the entirety of the
multiverse the different people that you
see embodying the power of the phoenix
are basically just kind of like
harbingers facsimiles of that version of
the phoenix in that particular universe
when a person's able to imbue what's
called the full totality of the phoenix
they're referred to as the white phoenix
of the crown a person who can basically
embody the whole of the phoenix force's
power and then they basically just hang
out in the white hot room all day and
they fix what's broken marvel never
explains that right it's just some weird
thing it's like well what does the
phoenix do they fix what's broken the
important thing is the phoenix has the
ability to wipe out whole universes and
recreate them but exactly what the role
the phoenix plays has never truly been
clear but the phoenix when it originally
showed up actually encountered an
alternate reality version of the
sorcerer supreme and was essentially
tricked into trying to merge the whole
multiverse together eventually it was
all stopped by like merlin and a handful
of people and then basically the guy was
defeated the phoenix forces kind of went
forward and did its own thing but
whenever a person is imbued with the
power of the phoenix their power just
skyrockets right they they get absurdly
powerful and it's kind of a cool thing
because if wanda were to come across the
phoenix force and you could really
create any circumstance as to why that's
happening right maybe wanda is like
losing her mind she's going on a rampage
or like destroying whole universes or
something along those lines and
disrupting how things are supposed to
exist the role that would normally be
provided for the living tribunal who
would see wanda's actions as a kind of
imbalance in the multiverse and probably
just destroy her uh would be reserved or
would be given to the phoenix well the
phoenix would say like you're creating
an imbalance here it's not how things
are supposed to be or wanda would just
come across an alternate reality version
of jean grey that has the power of the
phoenix and because gene doesn't
recognize her she's like you're not
supposed to be here and then like a
fight breaks out right now if a fight
were to happen between wanda and like
jean grey or or any character out there
as the white phoenix of the crown that's
a toss-up man there's no guarantee who
would win right it's just it's that
level of power right two multiversal
beings fighting off against each other
there's no real guarantee who would win
and in fact i would even go as far as to
argue if they were really fighting to
100 of their full potential they would
destroy the multiverse just this insane
level of power that's going on out there
would be absolutely absurd but it'd be
cool to see wanda fight the phoenix
right just because it'd be a huge level
of power again the big issue that you
have with this is the same issue you
have with everything else that marvel
cinematic universe largely just kind of
goes into concepts assuming nobody knows
anything about them which is a smart
move because you kind of get an
explanation and all that kind of stuff
and i have a hard time believing the
marvel that marvel studios is going to
introduce the phoenix into doctor
strange too give us an explanation of
her character which borderline's on
meditextual and then have one to fight
her and then it all makes sense right if
i'm being honest with you guys as much
as i love these choices for who wanda
would fight it's gonna be somebody
simple it's gonna be something like
silver surfer or it'll likely be magneto
or something along those lines where
marvel studios can largely just kind of
go on existing knowledge even if that
knowledge is not necessarily true
anymore because of the fact that the fox
properties may not necessarily exist the
way they previously did but have her
face off against michael fassbender's uh
magneto right or maybe they're lying
about hugh jackman and she fights hugh
jackman but it's gonna be something
where we go into it with an already
decent amount of understanding of what
would be going on so that people who are
not familiar with marvel comics won't be
lost balls at high weeds because at the
end of the day people would look at that
and say yeah man it's cool i don't
understand anything that happened but
it's cool
you know marvel studios wants to make
sure that people who go in and watch
their movies walk out of the movies or
at least are able to enjoy the movies
having an understanding of what's
happening now my job
on comments explained and here is to
make sure that if there is anything
you're confused about then i can clear
it all up for you but by and large
marvel studios like to take care of a
lot of that stuff in-house with the
writing of their characters things like
that so i love these picks i love these
choices and i'm curious to see what
yours are but at the end of the day if
we're being honest with ourselves having
wanda face off against somebody from the
fox properties most likely somebody with
regards to the x-men it would be
somebody like professor x magneto
possibly silver surfer because we're
familiar with him people kind of
understand the the value or at least the
power that he has the role he plays i
doubt it would be somebody like galactus
it certainly almost would never be
somebody like the phoenix but they're
they're their choices right they're
they're picks that i have that i think
would be amazing so let me know what you
guys think in the comments section who
would your number one pick be for who
wanda would face off against from the
fox properties from like the x-men or
the fantastic four the movies that were
previously made by fox let me know who
your choices are because i'm gonna be
coming through those comments and i
really wanna know who you guys would
pick but thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace